So now you see how in the coding region of the ABO Gene we can take a small
region. And see how it is turned from DNA into protein by playing into our
genetic code and coming up with those amino acids. Now, the interesting thing is
not everybody has the same sequence for the ABO Gene. Some people
have a different letter At position 796. So this is position
793, 94, 95, this would be position 796.
This C, this cytosine right here. Some people
have a cytosine, but not everybody. So one
person has a variation where that position 796
is changed to an A. And another person has a variation where that position 796
cytosine is changed to a T. I want you to tell me which variant you think would
have a more significant change compared to this original sequence that
we showed up here. Remember, make use of your genetic code here
that's given on the screen. If this is too small or
you can't read it well. Then you can also click on the
link in the instructor's notes to see, the full version of
the genetic code again. I want you to select which variant you
think is a more significant change. And then I want you
to explain why you think that is in this textbox right here.